[Música]
cada año en francia se venden miles de
monumentos de nuestro patrimonio
un mercado de nicho que este agente
inmobiliario experimentado trabaja desde
hace más de 30 años
entonces cuando visita un castillo su
ojo experto detecta rápidamente el
aspecto a tener en cuenta en el lugar
y
todo esto son cosas de calidad que se
hacían en el siglo 19
aquí hay series que sin duda fueron
recuperadas en una propiedad más antigua
no me extrañaría
cada detalle cuenta para determinar el
precio de un bien esta propiedad cuesta
varios billones de euros pero el
patrimonio francés es accesible para
todos los presupuestos
no es necesario ser millonario para
volverse propietario
una
edificación es de muy buena calidad poco
costosas entonces si uno se las apropia
se pueden hacer cosas maravillosas con
pocos recursos
en el contenta el agente inmobiliario
gestión o la venta de esta capilla por
85 mil euros el nuevo propietario
insiste en presentarle su proyecto para
rehabilitar el lugar próximo
la cubierta no está mal estado no no no
está bien también el centro el techo
está impecable
hay cosas que quiero conservar estos
muebles de iglesia me gusta mucho porque
tengo la intención de hacer seminarios
coloquios
el nuevo propietario quiere volver este
lugar un lugar de intercambios
culturales encuentros pero también un
lugar donde se pueda vivir una buena
parte del año
esta capilla está abandonada desde hace
dos años
algunas partes están muy dañadas
la obra será larga durará varios años
estas dos partes serán destruidas para
crear jardines que aportarán un poco de
humanidad no es un sacrilegio no no no
para nada si fuésemos a arrasar todo y a
construir un edificio sería un
sacrilegio pero si se trata de hacer
evolucionar el inmueble y conservar lo
que se puede salvar formidable
formidable os hay que hacerlo
evidentemente
gracias al proyecto de su nuevo
propietario esta capilla podrá iniciar
una segunda vida
[Música]
en bretaña el faro de carvel también
cambió de destino en el 2004
en aquella época su propietario logró
instalar una habitación en lo alto del
faro
se ven las obras las etapas porque es
extraordinario
aquí cortamos la parte baja de la
torrecilla la bajamos con esta grúa
y empezamos haciendo el techo en el
jardín luego levantamos esto ubicamos la
estructura metálica y levantamos el culo
[Música]
la nueva estructura se ensambla tal como
un rompecabezas de varias toneladas
y aquí el curso completo hay unos
cuantos soportes que se tuercen un poco
cuando levantamos cuando logramos
ubicarlos no es perfecto debemos forzar
un poco pero todo salió bien pudimos en
clavijas todo como se debía
hoy en día para llegar a la residencia
del faro hay que subir 126 escalones
cuando se llega arriba el espacio ha
sido optimizado al centímetro
el principio es poder disponer de una
parte de estudio de unos 20 metros
cuadrados había que bloquear la llegada
de la escalera entonces tenemos una
tabla que se va a yúnes cotillón de
socorro de todas formas si no hay
electricidad se puede descender
vamos a ver la linda vista
a 25 metros de altura el panoramas de
360 grados un pequeño corredor permite
dar la vuelta
es muy robusto no hay de qué preocuparse
hay vista al océano y hacia la ensenada
gloria lo vio esta vista increíble tiene
un precio
650 euros la noche una nueva vida para
un faro centenario
tras haber sido puesto en servicio en
1913 el faro de que abel es célebre por
haber sido uno de los pocos
administrados por una mujer o no y le
guen
durante 47 años cuido la lámpara que
guiaba a las embarcaciones
[Música]
tanto
monástica
hoy en día la torre de fuego ya no
ilumina el camino de las embarcaciones
en el suelo se le ha encontrado una
nueva función
el sauna funciona bien sí muy bien esta
torre fue codiciada en el momento de las
obras
algunas asociaciones pidieron recuperar
la torre de fuego para poner en el
centro de un rombo y yo quería que
permaneciera con el faro
faro abandonado capilla sin herederos el
patrimonio hace parte de nuestra vida
cotidiana sin que le prestemos atención
gracias a estos propietarios un poco
locos estos monumentos encuentran una
segunda juventud
[Música]